Pearl a dynamic interpreted scripting
language famous for its powerful text
processing abilities it was developed in
1987 by Larry wall a linguist who
designed it to feel more like a human
language than a computer language when
someone says Pearl they're usually
talking about version 5. there was a
version 6 under development but it
evolved into another language called
Raku Pearl is often referred to as a
glue language and has been dubbed the
Swiss Army chainsaw of the Internet it's
most commonly used to write CGI scripts
that allow web servers to communicate
with external programs its powerful
string parsing abilities has made it the
language of choice on high traffic sites
like DuckDuckGo booking.com and
Craigslist syntactically it resembles C
but is far more compressed allowing
developers to write very tourist code
like one-liners that hack together a
solution much quicker than other
scripting languages like python it
contains a large collection of language
Primitives and a ton of shortcuts for
getting things done quickly you may find
it ugly and awkward but system
administrators love it because it gets
the job done to get started install the
Pearl interpreter then create a file
ending in.pl it's a scripting language
so we start with a shebang and point it
to the interpreter's binary declare a
variable with a dollar sign then print
it to the standard output and the
variable can be easily interpolated into
another string variables can be scoped
locally with the my keyword or globally
to an entire package with the hour
keyword the dollar sign creates a scalar
variable which is a single value like a
string or number if we change the dollar
sign to the at symbol this variable
becomes an array the index of any item
in the array can be accessed with
brackets now name the variable with a
percent sign to get a hash or key value
pair to access one of its Keys use
braces one of the design principles of
pearl is things that are different
should look different handle conditional
logic using IF or unless then make it
more concise by refactoring it to one
line then make it even more concise
using the ternary operator one of the
most unusual things about Pearl is that
your functions are defined as
subroutines instead of defining
parameters within parentheses like most
other languages any arguments passed to
the function can be accessed with the at
underscore array when it comes to
parsing text regex is built in and The
Binding operator can easily match a
string to a regular expression Pearl
also has a lot of magic features like
Auto vivification where if we try to
increment a value in an array that
doesn't exist it will automatically
bring to life all the elements in
between now to render code open the
terminal and run The Interpreter this
has been Pearl in 100 seconds hit the
like button and subscribe if you want to
see more short videos like this thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one